ganz las vegas ist in trauer
dort lebten siegfried und leben
siegfried und roy und dort gab es ihre
bomben show im hotel mirage wir wollen
jetzt in die spielerstadt schalten nach
las vegas dort ist rené meinert vor ort
er ist tourguide in dieser stadt kennt
sie wie seine westentasche jahren eh wie
ist die stimmung in las vegas ja die
stimmung ist sehr getrübt in las vegas
die leute sind entsetzt jeder in las
vegas kennt siegfried und roy und
dementsprechend uns natürlich die trauer
groß
du stehst vor dem berühmten mirage im
hintergrund sehen wir auch eine statue
kommen dort fans hin konntest du mit
fans sprechen wie äußern sie sich zu
diesem tod gute nachricht von siegfried
von anschuldigungen von reus tod kam am
späten nachmittag in las vegas erst
durch es sind die ersten kerzen
aufgestellt worden die man hinter mir
sehen kann
momentan haben wir drei uhr nachts in
las vegas ist es keine person hier außer
zwei wach personen die nicht gefilmt
werden müssten die aufpassen dass hier
nichts passiert ich gehe davon aus dass
morgen hier alles komplett voll stehen
wird ops blum ops kerzen sind etc
ähnlich wie beim großen unfall am
dritten oktober 2003 war roy horn galt
ja als nahbar hast du ihn öfter in las
vegas gesehen wie ging er da auf die
menschen zu also ich kenn hauptsächlich
siegfried weil ich bin halt tourguide in
las vegas wir machen deutschsprachige
las vegas touren wir machen bei jeder
stadtrundfahrten halt bei siegfried und
roy zu hause am dschungel palast ab und
zu treffen wir den siegfried wenn er
zufällig rauskommt oder zufällig mit dem
auto ankommt immer sehr sehr freundlich
meine kunden fragen siegfried dann auch
wie g2 er nimmt sich auch wirklich zeit
erklärt wie es geht und wo man ihn
öfters gesehen hat im hofbräuhaus
das ist jetzt aber auch schon weiter ich
glaube beim letzten oktoberfest waren
nicht mehr da waren beide nicht mehr
dabei gewesen weil es ehrlich gesagt
auch immer mehr bergab ging mit roy
gemeinsames feiern im hofbräuhaus hat
sich roy horn trotzdem lange zeit
nicht nehmen lassen vielen herzlichen
dank meinert nach las vegas